we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine to david p here is a
voicemail reacting to the International
Business Times did a piece of last week
where I was included in a montage of
so-called comedians that were taking on
the issue of net neutrality and here's a
voicemail responding to that oh hey
David I just wanted to say that I saw
your clip next to Stephen Colbert and
john oliver and i have to say that you
are so the worst comedian that I've ever
heard you not funny at all oh okay yeah
but even comedy show right yeah this is
a comedy show and I'm a terrible
comedian that's what we figured out from
from this caller okay thank you very
much and i truly don't know if that was
serious or not it sounded very real now
he's joking yusei's joking you think
every lutely you think most hatred males
and voicemails or jokes I've noticed not
not most hatred males but a lot of the
voicemails I think they're trolling you
on the bonus show today I'm having a
major problem at my apartment here in
Boston I have not mentioned it Pat so
we're going to get his sort of honest
first reaction on the bonus show and
genuinely I actually am looking for
advice from from our members about how
to deal with this issue I'm having at my
apartment I'm also going to talk about
some major internal drama going on among
progressive media and I do want to talk
about a rare correction or retraction
issued by Fox News and it relates to the
Quebec mosque shooting that we told you
about yesterday so please sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership
today's bonus show is going to be a
doozy if the normal membership rates
strike you is high use the coupon code I
voted 17 to get a discount and I will
talk to you very soon on today's bonus
show